The Oreo has to cover this scenario,
right? Now, he'll try to avoid as much
as makes him look stupid as possible.
>> Oh, yeah, I don't even care. I don't
care.
>> No, you do care. You do care, and you're
in a miserable prison of your own body.
>> Uh, someone who posts videos of him
celebrating his birthday alone.
>> He spent his 21st birthday eating cake
alone on YouTube. This is bizarre. This
is very bizarre.
>> Cuz of him, it looks like he's not
comfortable wearing his own
skin.
>> [music]
>> So, I you know.
>> Classic Anissa projection.
Where's the lie? Where is the lie?
Anissa Jomha has apparently been
winning, guys. Has apparently been
winning, I've been hearing on my days
off.
>> The Oreo, what can I say? You do your
research.
>> [laughter]
>> Saying that Nicholas The Oreo does good
research is so funny.
So, I I think they I do think they get
along. They bond over the hate, and
that's you know, good for them.
>> [laughter]
>> You're done?
There it is. I know. I said I know. I
said I had one. That's my That's my Elon
impression.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, no.
That was the famous Elon That was, yeah.
It kills at parties. I had a poker event
that I did that at, and it did kill. So,
Adrian.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> Yeah, they both love Keno Casino,
obviously.
Because they love all and anything
deport deplorable and gross. Sorry,
Feltdimpt. I know you.
I know you like it there, but
>> So, I mean
I'm going to be real. That is like, uh
You know, this is a difficult clip to
attack, you know?
Like, what is the angle here? What angle
do you take? If you're
Let's imagine you're Let's imagine
you're a dishonest hack
rodent
who is desperate uh to simply
manufacture whatever narrative you can
that day about how Idubbbz Anisa Hassan
etc. are all just
disgusting low lives that you should
never even look at. You should hate them
with everything. And your entire your
entire life and position in your career
relies upon that being the narrative all
day every day cuz you could be cast out
by your boss at any point.
Let's imagine that's the position you're
in.
You would You might struggle to come up
with an angle on this.
Coping about the casino is really the
only out. There was no cope about the
casino. I'm sorry. [__] Keemstar
casino fans need to figure it out, okay?
I understand
your favorite show they can pull it off,
right? Andy Andy can't. PPP, the only
talented member of that show, PPP
can pull off
saying whatever narrative he wants,
basically. You know, he can usually pull
together enough pieces to make whatever
narrative he wants work in kind of like
a funny way.
You know, I I like PPP enough to give
him that.
Uh you as a mentally disabled PPP fan
cannot. So, saying something like coping
about the casino is the only out. There
was no cope there, okay? There was no
cope there. We don't have to pretend,
okay? You're not PPP. You don't have to
pretend for the show, okay? There's no
cope there. It is just a fact that they
do
quite quite deplorable gross stuff. It's
kind of part of the bit. That's part of
the fun.
PPP has done a lot of deplorable gross
stuff in his time, like
showing his [__] [__] on camera
and all this crazy [__]
You know, that's absolutely the case.
Getting in these drunken fights with
Surfer and all that [__] back in the
day.
Uh and it does not make sense that Ethan
and Hila claim to like them. That does
not make any sense.
And not only is that totally fine to
say, but Anisa is saying it to a Kino
Casino fan who is outwardly a Kino
Casino fan, uses the name Felted Imp,
obviously a reference, and allows them
to stay in her chat,
and interacts with them, does not sperg
out, does not cast them out, does not
tell them they can't be there, say, "We
don't We don't want people like you
here. You're You're right-wing. You're
right-wing. We don't want you
right-wingers here." Or some [__] like
that that they could easily jump on her
for. No, she's just saying
it's ridiculous that Ethan and Hila
pretend to like the show, cuz it is.
It is ridiculous. It is absurd.
But yeah, the Kino Casino dick riding
has got to end, okay? It's like
slightly amusing every once in a while,
but some of you guys that like Kino
Casino are totally unbearable retards,
and you clearly have disabilities.
>> It kills at parties. I had a poker event
that I did that at, and it did kill.
>> And they know that, too, by the way.
They know a bunch of their fans are
disabled. Like, you can just see that in
PPP's face sometimes.
>> Adrian.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, they both love Kino Casino,
obviously.
Because they love all and anything
depor- deplorable and gross. Sorry,
Felted Imp. I know you.
I know you like it there, but
>> So, yeah.
So, yeah, that's that's a little clip.
So, you might struggle to come up with
an attack on this.
Let's see what Nick goes with.
>> I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What
can I say? You do your research.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know.
>> I know.
>> Oh, yeah. I don't know if I ever watched
that, but I feel like I've heard that
before. There was some guy who got pedo
stung and said about being a Kino Casino
fan, some [__]
>> I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What
can I say? you do your research.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know. Not only is that
offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a
bad impression.
>> I'm a big fan of Nicholas De Oro.
>> So,
I I I thought it was mildly amusing,
personally.
But it's offensive? That seems odd for
Nick to say.
And here we see the cope recon here.
Mocking someone's accents or second
language speaking is offensive to most
communities partaking in targeting
healers this way.
That's not really an opinion, either.
So, now it's not He wasn't saying it's
offensive, guys. It was a double
standard point. It was a double standard
point. Except it wasn't, was it? You
said plainly it was offensive.
A huge double standard what people are
allowed to ethically mock. The caveat is
it's fair game to do this if the person
is hated enough. Ian and Anisa have
moved on from edgelords to woke scolds,
but constantly fall back into tactics
before. No bad tactics, only bad
targets, Anisa.
You'll take magic get all the way there
and right back around to being someone.
I never said it was meant to be a little
more of a throwaway line.
Just throw Just a throwaway line. Just
throw away the line.
So, this is [__] This isn't the
standard at all. It's not about whether
they're hated enough.
Uh they think mocking people if if
you're mocking someone
for doing something bad, they think
that's fine. If you're mocking someone
for for just being of
a descent, they have an issue with that
usually.
And I also like how baked into this this
edgelords to woke scolds thing
is basically he's supplanting
Ian's entire change in perspective
onto Anisa.
It is so a given, so fact in the mind of
these people
that Anisa just told Ian to change
that
he thinks they're like on the exact same
page. It couldn't possibly be that it's
not remotely possible
that maybe Anisa has less of an issue
with edgy jokes than than Ian does these
days.
That could That couldn't possibly be
true. No, it has to be the case
because it's always been the case
because that's the story that they've
decided in their head for the last 6
[__] years.
That Anisa told him to change and that
Ian's new perspective is Anisa's
perspective. But I've never actually
heard Anisa say "I've had a big change
in perspective." I've never heard that
from Anisa.
And what I have heard from both Ian and
Anisa is that Anisa helped on a lot of
the old iDubbz videos.
So I have no reason to believe that
Anisa isn't okay with like some kind
some kinds of edgy jokes. I have no
reason to believe that
Anisa's not okay with with some of that.
Now, would she
be okay if you were just Okay, how do we
try to supplant this, right?
Let's try and supplant this onto some
other situation
to try and see whether there's a double
standard here.
So what's what's really happening here?
Because in their mind it is not as
simple as mocking an accent.
Would they think that simply mocking an
accent
because you dislike people of that
background or look down upon people of
that background
and so you want to mock them for being
of that ethnic background or whatever or
or national background or whatever.
Would they think that's okay as just
like a thing? No, probably not. There's
probably some
factor here that is making it okay.
And I think we can probably point
towards their beliefs. I think we can we
can probably indicate
we we probably find indication that it's
about their beliefs. And so I don't
think there's really hypocrisy here.
Like the
They They They go after her
on that basis
because they believe her to be
like a racist
backwards
uh What would you say? Like what It It's
like mocking um
You know I got I thought this is This is
a comparison I'm slightly maybe stealing
from Hasan's defense of himself, but it
it it is sort of like mocking hicks.
It's like mocking trailer the trailer
trash hicks. You wouldn't usually mock
You know, a lefty wouldn't you just mock
a poor person.
But a poor racist, that's a different
issue.
It's almost like a um
Like what would you say? Like what How
would you describe it? It's almost like
you don't you don't hold these
You don't hold other people with
dignity, so why should other people hold
you with dignity, you know? It's almost
like that.
So if you If you're If you don't show
disrespect to other groups
then why do we respect you along those
lines?
And Ethan and Hila and the H3 defense
force
are the absolute last people
that can cry about this uh like
perceived hypocrisy.
Because we just have to look back.
Yeah, how many times
has Ethan cried about snarkers this,
snarkers that, they say this stuff this
mean stuff about me.
There's mean personal stuff about me.
And then the moment you got into a fight
with Ian and Anisa, it was
a full year of the most bizarre
sexual comments, aggressive sexual
jokes, calling in all their friends and
their trainers and [__] to call in and
ask about their personal lives and make
a bunch of like sexual theories about
their relationship. So it is it's
It just comes from such a disingenuous
place. I've even No, Ethan he'll avoid
Red Bar like crazy.
Yeah, Ethan does not fight, man. Facts.
See, I just don't know how you even go
about this, bro.
Anissa's just one.
Is this going to be members only?
>> At least I have the balls to show my
face when I'm talking. Who?
>> Okay, dude.
>> Sick of what looking at
>> So, okay, here's the other element. So,
this is what we're leading into a bit
here.
Anissa is
full steam ahead on the Oreo snark,
okay?
Anissa's full steam ahead.
Because uh
I also just showed that tweet a moment
ago.
A sleepy tweet.
This one here. Sleepy Anissa has
actually been interacting with Sleepy's
tweets, quote tweeting, and replying
to Sleepy's tweets about the Oreo.
Which is quite funny. It's It's quite
funny. It's It's It's amusing seeing her
do the same [__] that Hassan's been
pulling for the last
couple months.
I've just like
you know, starting to make little jabs
here and there and then just
dipping into the
the end of the the the drama
commentators that are that are pressing.
We love to see it. We love to see it.
We love to see it.
The Oreo has to cover this now, right?
No, he'll try to avoid as much of the
[__] that makes him look stupid as
possible.
But, he does watch this, but he does
watch this.
>> If you were podcasting my way now, I'm I
don't know. Don't you get sick of
>> No, Nick did pinball streams as well.
>> Looking at the do the But, I'm competing
directly with Ethan's channel.
was dying. Here's some empathy shekels.
We actually have dropped a couple, and
that's cuz on most nights I'm competing
directly with Ethan now. Like Ethan's
channel, like we were all we were almost
always over 4,000. Some nights we dip in
our
our max dips under 3,000 now, but I'm
competing directly with Ethan's channel.
Like there's a 4,000 viewer podcast in
my way now.
>> I'm I don't know. Don't you get sick of
what looking at the do the roar again?
>> Dude, he launched another show.
>> I Although, I guess that's why he has
the little a
>> Dude, uh stiffed by absolutely [__]
stiffed by Guam is crazy, bro.
You got muscled out of your time slot by
[__] Guam and Harley Zogbenstein.
Are you for real, bro? Are you for real?
>> animated avatar, right? Tiny streaming
is back. It is.
Okay.
At least I have the balls to show my
face when I'm talking. Who um Nick
>> Bro, I don't Dude, listen. If I did
that, I would have everyone being like,
"Did he just shower?" Or did he just Or
is his hair greasy like your husband?
Dude, the time that it would take to
have to set up a camera and do all that
like other editing and [__] like that.
It's so easy to just log in, have
nothing to do. Just I don't even have to
like look around or or or care about I I
could do literally anything.
I could be texting while I'm in the
middle of the segment, you guys wouldn't
know. It is so optimized to the point
where everything that I do on here
>> What did I say, guys? What did I say?
FPM.
Positively persistence.
Every time.
That's this guy's life. That is this
guy's life from day [__] one.
Sit on your ass. Eat your [__] slop.
Watch your Family Guy.
Every day of this guy's [__] life.
And he Yeah, and he is
pretend He wants to pretend that it's
just like, "Oh, yeah. I don't even care.
I don't even care." No, you do care. You
do care. And you are in a miserable
prison of your own body.
>> counter or or care about I I could do
literally anything.
I could be texting while I'm in the
middle of the segment, you guys wouldn't
know. It is so optimized to the point
where everything that I do on here is as
little effort as humanly possible.
>> insulting me because you don't face cam
because you've moved up a weight bracket
since last time.
That's so true. That's so true. I
literally I I don't face cam. If my hair
is like slightly off,
I'm I'm not face camming. I'm not going
to I'm not going on stream today.
>> Twitter.
>> Thank you.
If we do panel streams, I'll be on
camera, but until then, everything that
I do is optimized to do as little effort
as humanly possible. It's to like
running the channel on auto.
>> [__]
>> Ego check. Does Nick have more Twitch
subs?
>> No way. There's no way I do. We haven't
pushed the Twitch in a while.
>> Nick DiOrio, aka Epic
>> I'm a mister [__] Oh, wait, dude.
Wait, hold on. Hold on. This is This is
a [__] I can hear it. I can smell a
donation clip. Please call me Mr. Rape
Man or Mr. Rape Reviewer Man, please.
>> to show my face when I'm talking.
>> Who? Um Nicholas DiOrio, aka
>> It's not about the snark cuz I I came on
pretty much straight away with the with
the chopped hair cut just to like, you
know, get out of the way.
It's not about the snark. It's like I
will
I am a freak.
I am a freak. Okay. This is
If I even if I ever even explained
uh you know, my internal thought
process, people would think I'm like
crazy. I would I'm like legit crazy.
I'm like legit insane.
You know?
>> Review what's
>> who you easily [__]
>> I would just sit there. I would obsess
over, you know, my hair being slightly
off.
I will stare at it.
It will bother me. It will send me
[__] insane.
No one will even say anything.
And I'll just be sitting there looking
at it.
>> Holy [__] I'm sorry your channel is
dying.
>> Yes! Thank you.
>> Everyone, pay him now.
>> I appreciate it. Oh, did we She cut
herself off. I have to do a little a
little magic to make this a little bit
more
>> space when I'm talking.
>> Oh, [__] Dude, Mr. Rape Man.
>> Who um Nicholas DeOrio, aka Epic Rape
Review. What's his What's the name of
his
>> Wait, is she going to say it?
Hold on. Wait, is she going to call it
Ultimate Rape Review? She's not going to
call it Rape Review, right? That'd be
[__] up.
>> Uh channel rev
Ultimate Rape Review, I THINK.
>> YES! [screaming]
>> THE NAME OF IT?
>> A PERSON? WHO WHO IS BOOGIE KING?
>> OH MY GOD, this is so awesome.
>> Sorry, I can't help but see a poor
wannabe rape reviewer talking about
money. We all know THE DRILL.
>> LET'S [__] GO!
>> HOW DO YOU FIX IT IN 5 TO 10 MINUTES?
NO, if my hair is not done right leaving
the shower, then it's [__] for the
whole day.
I don't even want to go into my hair
process. I don't want to talk about it.
>> think. Yeah. Oh, no, I'll tell you. So,
there's this creature
um named Nicholas DeOrio. And Nicholas
DeOrio
>> This is awesome.
>> Orio, okay, is uh someone who posts
videos of him celebrating his birthday
alone.
Which again
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, I got I don't I don't know if
Nissa knows the truth or if she's joking
here.
Dude, no way. And Nissa said the
[laughter] the [__] birthday boy
clip.
Dude,
what?
This is my snark. This is my snark.
This is my snark. How is this going
around? How is this a thing now?
>> I'll tell you. So, there's this creature
um named Nicholas DeOrio. And Nicholas
DeOrio
>> This is awesome.
>> Orio, okay, is uh someone who posts
videos of him celebrating his birthday
alone.
Which again
>> When did I do that?
>> It's from a She got that from a tequila
tweet. Let's go, bro. Let's go. Send me
the tweet, tequila. Send me the tweet.
Send me the tweet.
>> problem. But, if
>> Wait, when the [__] DID I DO THAT?
>> [laughter]
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW. MAYBE
>> JAVI, just play the game. $30,000.
>> I AM THREE.
>> WAIT,
>> [laughter]
>> at or something. He doesn't really
>> He posts videos of himself celebrating
his birthday alone.
He does do that.
Hasn't for a He used to. It's not coming
up. He used to. Hasn't for a long time.
I think he's waiting to slim down before
it comes up again. But, he's been out
eating the zampy for the last couple of
years.
But, this doesn't say birthday. This
doesn't say anything about being his
birthday.
That's like a specific thing. That's the
specific claim is that this is him
eating his birthday cake alone.
That's like a specific claim. Where is
she getting that from?
>> Strike me as a
>> We don't do a birthday stream.
>> cat guy Celebrate the birthday of your
birthday with a cat, dude. But, he
doesn't even have that.
>> Wait, I lit- Dude,
>> on Nicholas DeOrio.
>> Wait,
>> The crazy part is
>> Hi, Anissa. Hope you enjoy me giving
Nick
>> even think that's true.
>> We have like a
>> [laughter]
>> I don't even think that's actually true.
>> and Keemstar Orbiter, Nick Oreo, Mr.
Oreo.
>> Shalome UJR comes to the rescue of your
dead channel.
>> Oh my god. Cuz that was the day that we
had like the huge [__] snowstorm. I
don't even think I was alone that day.
>> Watching Anissa's stream live feels like
watching animals
>> It's my birthday. I wasn't alone.
>> Anyways, have a
good birthday.
>> [laughter]
>> Bro, you're dissing Sophie right now, my
dog.
>> Dude,
>> Facts, the only other person I have
heard of
>> I'm a [__] black-pilled on this [__]
>> Dude, dude, dude, dude.
>> a welfare. Here's my hard-earned cash to
keep you afloat after paying 420 pinball
machines. Fun fact, the only other
person I have heard say "smell like
pennies" is Sam Hyde.
>> Okay. Can I say something to you, Nick?
I really like you.
Why?
>> Why? All right. All right, look. Look.
In in [__] 2000 and what year is
this? 2018,
I posted
I posted this video
and I think she thinks this is my
birthday.
>> Love the turnout. So, if somebody
reached out to me and sent me some
stuff.
>> Oh god, this is a story. This is like my
second video ever.
>> And looking at that information, it's
kind of like I don't know.
Having your cake.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick? I
really like you. Why?
And you need it, too.
>> Does she think this was my birthday?
This was a bad bit in a video in 2018.
What is this actually my Ethan Ralph
video? The intro of this
>> do the impossible.
>> And we'll have more to say later, I'm
sure.
There's a lot out there on you, buddy,
so
we'll see what happens. But, I just
wanted to show you
>> to go in for two bites, dude.
He's doing it for the bit in the video,
but he just couldn't stop himself. He
had to go in for a second bite.
>> I don't know.
Having your cake.
>> The like the one bite Okay, Nick, you've
done the bit. I think you've done the
bit for the video.
Uh Nick.
No, Nick, just just say the line, Nick.
Nick, there's another part of the You're
still reading a script, Nick. The
camera's rolling.
>> I really like you.
Why?
I really enjoy that. Really say that.
>> You need it, too. Does she think this
was my birthday?
>> [laughter]
>> day? This was a bad bit in a video in
2018.
What is this actually my Ethan Ralph
video? The intro of this goes hard.
>> the impossible.
>> And uh we'll have more to say later, I'm
sure.
Uh there's a lot out there on you,
buddy, so
we'll see what happens. But I just
wanted to show once and for all that I'm
not actually 5'1.
>> [laughter]
>> That's for the Ralph video. Did she
think that that was my birthday?
>> He I don't know.
>> How old were you then? Probably 21.
>> I always DO THE POSSIBLE.
>> [laughter]
>> UH BUT ANYWAYS, HE is a commentary one
of these
>> His mugshot.
>> That was 20 Wait, that was his 21st
birthday?
He spent his 21st birthday eating cake
alone on YouTube.
>> 5'1 No, shut up. It does not. The new
one? I'll show you something to you,
Nick.
>> I really like you.
>> It's commentary slap guys. And he has
this
>> Your voice sounded different. That's the
Blue Yeti. I'm on the um I'm on the the
Shure SM7B now.
>> segment. I've heard whispers
>> to you, Nick.
>> Um cuz there's no way I would sit
through a whole hour. How
>> Bro, she literally admitted that she
watched my stream.
>> Isn't that the Hasan code?
Isn't that the same code Hasan uses for
why he sounds like a
>> other day and now she's heard whispers
of it.
>> How long does he stream for?
She heard
>> She HEARD CHINESE WHISPERS.
>> STREAMS FOR a while. Um but he has this
segment called the ultimate rape review
where he reviews
uh rape cases and decides
>> [cheering]
>> Stewie Hebrews.
>> [music]
>> So unfunny, bro.
>> I can't believe the year is 2026.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick?
>> This is probably the best This was my
best financial decision ever was the was
the [__] host Ultimate Rape Review.
I don't think we've done one of these
like actual named streams in like
Hebrews. It has been my best financial
decision in history.
>> I mean, called the Ultimate
>> People ask if you can go back to back in
time and not host Ultimate Rape Review.
I'd be like, "What are you talking
about?"
>> Ultimate Rape Review where he reviews
uh
>> But the thing is that he lies about it.
This is the thing, right? We've been
over this before is that him and all the
other H3 audience lie about Ultimate
Rape Review was.
They lie and say it wasn't reviewing
rapes
when it was. That is exactly what you
did.
>> uh rape cases and destroyed
>> Can you just get it right? I don't
review rape cases. I review Ultimate
Rape Cases. It's like Ultimate Frisbee.
It's like a different thing.
>> decides whether or not um the woman is
lying.
So
>> And we have the funny meter where we
rate their queers.
>> And that's
>> it like
So he's having to add in like absurdist
elements to try and cope to his audience
that's not exactly what it was cuz he
knows he's got a bunch of like raped
wine moms in his audience now who got
like
nonstop.
So
he has to like pretend that he didn't do
that when he did.
>> Turkey Tom URR, that was true. We did a
Turkey Tom URR.
>> By the way, who Ethan and Ela watch and
enjoy. They think he has really good
research.
>> Dude, Ethan loves Ultimate Rape Review.
He's watched every single episode.
Quoted directly from Ela with that.
>> So um that's that's
>> Billy Mitchell and Shad and Ethan and I
are the gifts that keep on giving. Hell
yes, dude, especially when you use code
Nick on Ricky's hot sauce.
>> who that is.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick?
>> It's vile.
>> like
>> Ela said yeah, Ela said that he's her
favorite and uh she donates to this uh
in
>> Ela sent me a super chat.
It had to be a year ago.
>> And
>> And this is Hebrews.
>> So she read a snark thread and went,
"Oh, dude, I've got all the information
I need to go in on this [__] guy."
>> Cool. And if you look at him like a
picture of him, he doesn't like stream
himself.
Uh which I
>> Stoic. Hebrews.
>> Thank you.
>> what he looks like, I get. Uh because he
looks like he should be holding a giant
>> Oh, this is such a rough picture.
Our dude really looks crazy in this
picture.
I see this thing as well, bro.
>> oversized lollipop at all times.
>> Jesus Christ.
>> You know, he is shorter than Augie,
isn't he?
I think so, right? Unless it's like a
perspective thing. I think he's got to
be shorter than Augie.
But do we know Augie's height? Is Augie
like 5'6"?
I feel like I've heard someone say that.
Dude, if Nick is like actually 5'5"
Hey.
>> By the way, the issue that she has here
>> have careful screen.
>> Oh my god, we keep getting [__] raped
with donations. This is the actual URL.
Holy [__] Thank you.
>> you lied to us about having dogs. Whose
dogs did you even show us?
>> Dude, I showed you I stole those dogs.
They're not even legally mine, bro.
>> [snorts]
>> The thing is Anissa is the one with like
crippling self-image problems. That's
kind of her jam. So, I mean
>> [snorts]
[laughter]
>> What?
What?
Yeah, dude, you are 400 lbs.
This is bizarre. This is very bizarre.
>> Thank you.
>> you lied to us about having dogs.
>> Dude, that she has here
>> have careful screen.
>> god, we keep getting [__] raped with
donations. This is the actual URL. Holy
[__] Thank you.
>> you lied to us about having dogs. Whose
dogs did you even show us?
>> Dude, I showed you I stole those dogs.
They're not Not legally mine, bro.
The thing is Anissa is the one with like
crippling self-image problems. That's
kind of her jam. So, I mean, swing away.
>> I get it.
>> I think he also lied about having a
girlfriend and then got outed for
>> No way.
>> lying.
>> Do the roar.
>> Do the tooth and roar, goddammit.
>> Dude, no one no one responds to that
one.
>> We're still doing the fake girlfriend
allegations.
>> Oh, there we are.
>> Send it to Twitch just so Nick can brag
about having a channel he doesn't use
has more subs than her.
>> Oh my god. Dude, you I don't need my
chat promoting my dead Twitch. They're
going to think it's [__] money
laundering.
>> He has no dogs. He's belted. He has no
belts.
>> I'm dogless.
>> Honeybee, honeybee, honeybee.
>> [laughter]
>> So, I yeah.
It and he's talking
>> insulting me viciously on Twitter.
>> Was this an inside job? Are you
parlaying with Anissa? Also, leg leg leg
leg leg leg leg leg leg leg leg leg leg
leg leg leg leg leg.
>> I mean, it would make a lot more sense.
>> Nicholas De Oreo streamed about this
last night, and after watching Nick's
stream, I'm kind of [__] black-pilled
on this [__]
>> Dude, again though, if we want to talk
about if we want to talk about crippling
self-image problems, I did see this 3
days ago.
>> Not I don't know.
>> But wait, why are we showing this?
>> Not
>> I mean, it would make a lot more sense.
>> Nicholas De Oreo streamed about this
last night, and after watching
>> if we want to talk about crippling
self-image problems, I did see this 3
days ago.
>> Not
>> [music]
>> I don't know.
>> So,
random people, people on the internet,
say she's ugly.
>> Really, really hot women
tell [music] me that I'm pretty.
Also,
thank you. So, I just don't
>> Ur is a failure.
>> Yeah, we we got to her. We got to her.
Guys, we got to her. All the ugly posts
finally got to her. We won. We won. She
We won. Let's go.
>> is sent on behalf of Anissa's close
friend, Hila Klein.
And
about us for a long
>> What part of that was supposed to show
me that she's like got crippling
self-image issues to the point where
her making fun of your parents makes no
sense.
She said She's saying she can't present
herself
as someone that thinks they're hot.
She can't do the posing Instagram [__]
Instead, she does like [__] quirky
dances. It's like a It's like this is
[__] that women say all the time. This
is just like quirky woman [__] dude.
This isn't like
So, like I I don't
How do you explain this to someone? This
is quirky woman [__] It's not
women on the brink of killing herself
[__]
This isn't crippling self-image issues.
This is like
Tumblr.
>> I wish I thought I was [music] hot. Not
like I wish I was hot.
Cuz like I don't know.
Even if I was hot, I don't think I would
think [music] that I was hot. I wish
that I
>> how do you convey this?
>> that I was hot. I feel like you can just
[music] tell.
>> You can, to be clear. You can.
>> about us for a long time. Um
and I didn't
>> commentator of the year.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I am
going to cut this cuz we are
>> Yeah, it's
>> I'm not like other girls. I just stay in
and read and wear my hair in a messy
bun. Yeah, exactly. There you exactly
how I do. Thank you.
>> Want to say we love our legs, everyone
in chat. If you also love legs, please
spam chat with legs.
>> Please don't spam chat with legs. No,
it's not sponsored by legs. Thank you.
Thank you.
>> talk about him one because I'm not
really online, but two I I also just
feel bad for him.
I think out of all the slot tubers, I
feel the worst for him because
yeah.
Not good. Even when you see pictures
>> Wait, he has no control over his life.
He's a controlling guy. He's called on
this [__]
>> Dude.
>> [laughter]
>> is of him, it looks like he's not
comfortable wearing his own
skin. So, I you know.
>> Classic Anissa projection.
>> Where is the lie? Where is the lie?
[__] looks like um you know when you know
in Doctor Who, you know in Doctor Who
guys in the Chris Rock the ones where
the Silene still those people suits,
those people skin suits.
And they're like these big fat dudes
that are like farting and [__]
>> Why don't you guys be nice, aren't we?
>> Thank you.
>> Here's to the 4,000 concurrent viewers.
That makes her super viral.
Anissa's viral at 250 viewers. Go buy a
victory watch.
>> He's making bank off of you. It's He's
making bank off of Ethan and Ela. I
There's quite the talent of uh
>> Wait.
>> I think she is saying you need to stream
proper like she does and show your face
and wear a low-cut t-shirt.
>> Yes. Wait.
>> we going to see this?
>> You think that
>> Wink.
>> You think that if There's two things
that happen right now. One, if you and
iDubbbz quit
>> streaming
>> I have to moderate that message.
I unfortunately I do have to moderate
that message. A 5-minute time out for
Jizzlane Maxwell.
>> Or two,
>> the Oreo commentator of the year, the
best commentator of the year.
>> Thank you.
If you and Ian quit streaming, I would
lose significantly more money
than if Ian stopped talking about drama.
That's just a fact. Like the iDubbbz and
an Esa segments
make a killing and they don't require
Ethan responding to them.
>> finding some Like we
>> don't cover every Ethan Klein drama he's
doing.
>> one who's just a little bit dumber than
you.
>> Yeah, cuz some of some of them cuz some
of them are are tough to defend them in.
So, you shouldn't cover those ones. We
know.
>> prey on them, but Nicholas DeOra is
getting eaten by his own. I heard that
he's becoming a lolcow himself, so and
that's the fate, isn't it, of those
creatures? He's making bank. How many
people watch that content? I think he
gets like 4,000 viewers on average.
>> Yep. Yes.
>> average. But, that's what I wanted to
share with you guys. Next, okay? Wait,
is it illegal to share your wishes?
Guys,
>> Oh my god. Jesus Christ.
>> You get in trouble for that? Is that
Will I go to jail if I share my wishes?
>> Brian come out of this. I have to be
really picky.
>> Because me No. [laughter]
Let's like not.
So, uh me and Ian had a rotisserie
chicken.
>> Holy [__] dude. Epic black Oh, epic
bacon blackface. Thank you.
>> Epic bacon blackface also says we all
love our leg. Never hush the legs we
love our legs.
>> Thank you epic bacon making blackface.
>> Holy [__] dude.
>> Again, it's illegal not to. We had a
rotisserie chicken after working out.
And I found the wishbone. And I was
like, "Oh my god, we should do a
wishbone wish."
>> Tell me that they tell me they broke a
[__] wishbone and they wish that my
viewers would dwindle like her eggs.
Please. Please.
Uh, dude. Uh.
Yuck, man.
Yuck.
What am I hearing from this guy?
I cannot overstate enough this guy
sounds like such a disgusting rapist
whenever he tries to make fun of women.
Sounds like Sounds like, just to be
clear, defamation warning.
Sounds like a rapist.
It's crazy.
This guy's actually on some Stefan
Molyneux [__]
This guy going to be Guys, someone mock
up a bunch of edits of old Stefan
Molyneux tweets about Taylor Swift and
just swap out the names and everything
for me.
Please tell me they did that.
>> Please tell me they put like a gypsy
curse on my channel.
>> So, we both made a wish and we pulled on
the bone and I won.
>> My eggs are dwindling.
>> Thank you. Tell me right now.
>> Antonio Ray.
>> Tell me that they've moved to a higher
power to try to stop my channel's
growth.
>> subscribing. It wasn't from Costco or
Superstore. It was
>> Please stop interrupting her. Something
funny could be happening here.
>> Um, Safeway. And I wished for an average
of 1,000 viewers a stream.
And I pulled
>> Aw, it's for her. Rap.
>> that thing and I got the majority. So,
if magic is real,
>> To be clear though, in comparison to
your husband, you still probably have
the majority.
>> in the next
3 months I'll get an average of 1,000
viewers per stream. If magic is real. If
it's not real, well,
what's the point?
>> Do you got to talk to Casey Tronc.
>> Let's be hard work instead.
That
Anissa
There's a path.
It just requires endless Nicholas
DeOrio's nog, okay?
Just believe me. Believe me.
Yeah, that's
>> Oh, wait, what?
>> Good.
>> I support it. I support it.
Uh but now I'm going to pee.
Sane class.
>> Oh, dude, I saw the other one. It's that
with class now. So, what is this class?
>> The goat. Thank you for the $5, buddy.
>> to charge your crystals with USB-C.
>> outstrips supply. There's a There's a
huge problem in the market right now.
>> Obesity. WHAT?
>> YES, DUDE. BEST CHATTER. DUDE, THE BEST
chatter is locked in.
>> Welcome to the salad boys.
>> Nick, your streams aren't unlisted. They
were unlisted when I started. Maybe they
published after.
>> Okay, let me
>> But we have the clip now, so we don't
need it.
>> Nicholas DeOrio
>> Keffals appreciated the shout-out.
>> is my favorite chatter.
I think this is the same clip. It's not.
No, it's definitely not the same clip.
>> tell you guys something. I'll tell you a
little secret. Love your makeup today.
Thank you. Oh my god, yeah. I just
realized I ACTUALLY LIKE
>> OH, NO. WHAT AM I GOING TO DO?
>> THANK YOU.
>> It's leg day, leg, leg, leg, leg, leg,
leg, leg, leg, leg.
>> How does it feel to be a lolcow who
celebrates his birthday alone?
>> have milked that so much harder. Big
content strategy problem.
>> thing I'm going to do is uh
is release
>> How does it feel to be a lolcow who
celebrates his birthday alone?
>> Dude, the next thing I'm going to do is
[__]
I I was going to make an Ethan Ralph
thing, but I don't want to say that I'm
going to [__] post revenge porn or
whatever unironically or I'll get
clipped.
>> Did a wing. Look at I'm so 2016.
>> Dude, the [__] Being a lolcow in 2026 is
awesome. You could either post revenge
porn, die in a Ukrainian prison, uh
>> [laughter]
>> join a podcast and make up a shitload of
money while degrading yourself
constantly. Or um whatever Bowblax is
doing.
You have so many options these days.
>> Hebrews.
>> There's so many avenues of failure.
>> Slay.
>> [laughter]
>> I have like the aggressive wing and
everything.
Um
>> You can become Cyrax. I don't know
enough about Cyrax.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick? I
really like you.
>> Why?
>> Thank you. In the Elon Klein accent, I
will say
Oh, yeah. I need to figure that out.
Play music, but I can't hear it so I can
focus. I
>> Dude,
is this like your [__] fifth stream
so far? She hasn't figured out the music
thing.
>> I'm sure my husband can help me.
Husband.
Um
>> Okay, I'll give you the answer. This is
how you do it. You literally just need
to put the music on, have a playlist of
approved songs, and if you don't want to
hear it cuz I assume that your issue is
it's like the way that people don't want
to hear themselves when they're
podcasting and that would [__]
trigger the hell out of me if I could
hear myself. Then just put it on a
channel that you can't hear but the
stream can. That's literally the
solution to your problem.
>> Um I I will say
>> She doesn't understand channels. Like
that's that's that's the solution. You
can do that immediately.
>> I was not expecting that to go viral.
Can you hear me?
I was not expecting that clip to go
viral.
Now it's blocking my excellent cleavage.
>> Okay, this is the same clip. Is there
anything at the end here?
>> What? That's what I wanted to share with
you.
>> Crippling self-image issues, guys.
>> It's the wishbone clip.
>> Next.
Okay. Wait, is it illegal to share your
wishes?
>> Okay.
>> For an average of a thousand viewers a
stream
and I pulled that thing and I got the
majority.
So
>> Isn't it crazy that if I [__] totally
screwed up and I lost half my viewers, I
would still have double what she dreams
about at night?
>> If magic is real
>> You have to set your [__] goals a
little higher, dude. The guy who's
inspired by your husband is [__]
mauling you.
>> Oh.
>> In the next
>> Dude, it's like so tough to listen to.
It's this just forced bravado that just
you just hear the insecurity, man.
>> was twice the person at half the weight
than you'll ever be, you living olive
oil cask bippity boppity [__]
>> Thank you for the $4.99, Jiminy. Thank
you.
>> 3 months, I'll get an average of a
>> [laughter]
>> All right, ladies and gentlemen. You
used to have big dreams of traveling to
China.
She's working on her Chinese language
skills.
>> click off of that.
>> Yeah, we've been learning Chinese. We
want to do a trip
>> next
3 months, I'll get an average
>> You're [__] with
>> Share your
>> I'm glad.
Is there anything at the end here?
>> What? That's what I wanted to share with
you guys.
>> It's a wishbone club.
>> Next. Or about the majority.
>> my viewers
>> set your
>> I guess my [__] is all
>> dreams of traveling to China.
She's working on her Chinese language
skills.
>> Yeah, we've
>> to be fake. This is going to be fake.
>> been learning Chinese. We want to do a
trip to China.
>> Yeah, we're going to go to China soon.
[music]
We've been learning Chinese.
>> to go to a shaman to get
get 1/4 of my viewers.
>> Here Here's my
>> Oh, she's going to do some Chinese.
>> Xie xie.
Xie jian.
Uh lai lai lai.
>> Guys, I apologize. [laughter]
>> Trigger warning if you're Chinese in my
chat. What you're about to hear is some
of the most offensive content you'll
ever go and witness.
>> Uh this is awesome.
>> Dude, guy watches [__] uh
>> [laughter]
>> watches anime for 3 seconds. Actually,
that's
Where Where do the people who watch
anime go? I don't respect you.
>> Yeah, [laughter] WE'VE BEEN
>> OH, NO. WHAT AM I GOING TO DO?
>> been learning Chinese. We want to do a
trip to China.
>> Is it all Japan, or is it just like the
whole You got to go to Tokyo, but you
also got to go to Beijing and stuff. I
thought it's both. Cuz I know anime
people also go to like anime people. I
mean people who like anime, not anime
people. It's like
>> I know.
>> They also like Korea and stuff. It's
kind of that whole East Asia thing,
right?
>> I'm going to go to China soon.
>> Is it just Japan? I thought it was like
China, Japan, and Korea.
>> We've been learning Chinese. Here's my
>> Oh, she's going to do some Chinese.
>> Shu shu
shu jen
>> I saw a post today. How offensive is
this or is this accurate? People were
saying that like you know that you're
one like when you hear dude like it was
like POV your one gooner friend, let's
go to Japan was like a thing. Is that
like a Is that like also a major sex
tourism area as well?
Or cuz I saw the comments were all like
making fun of the guy and saying
>> commentator of the year, the best
commentator of the year.
>> Is it?
>> Go east.
>> Because the people were commenting
saying that people watch one anime and
think that Japan is a [__] dating
simulator.
>> [laughter]
>> The least gooner guy you know, hey guys,
let's go to Japan. I think we can go on
a bros trip to Japan.
>> Uh
>> Most countries can be.
>> Lie lie lie.
>> Not really.
>> I could see that being more of a place
for that.
>> lost. This is
>> The reason why Nick is support Ethan is
because his girlfriend is Jewish.
>> Okay, thank you for the dialogue. I
thought his girlfriend was like Asian or
some [__]
>> Um
>> Lie lie lie is like
>> it was like some fat Asian.
Why do I Why do I think it's a fat
Asian? Where have I heard that?
>> Go go.
>> Cuz we were covering that other guy, the
Gujun Goomba, but his thing was Japan,
right? Like he was just obsessed with
Japanese culture.
>> I thought it was like come come
>> And then he gave his Goomba wife tits.
And I'm not making a joke about her
height. She was like a Goomba
avatar.
>> Yeah, like kind of like
like yellow.
>> Japan is East. Yeah, I know, but like I
guess I haven't watched enough of Legal
Mindset to know which are the most
>> Okay, we queuing his expert opinion
here.
This is very telling. He's trying to
make himself not a creep.
So, he's trying to present as though he
doesn't understand anything about
traveling to Asia or the reason someone
might travel to Asia or Japan or China
or anything like that. So, that it's
like I've never I've never even thought
about I'm so not yellow fever. I've
never even thought about it.
I've never even considered it. I don't
even I don't watch anime. I've never
even thought about it.
Not even for a second would I ever
consider going to an Asian country.
And certainly not to sleep with Asian
women.
Right. That's what we're saying. That's
that's the snark here. Okay.
He's got some fat Asian girlfriend and
he has to pretend like he's never
considered
traveling to Japan or any other country
for any reason associated with anything
from the internet, especially not
anything related to sex.
>> Most [__] locations.
>> Like Vamanos.
>> Yeah, and um what's the other one? Oh
>> Yeah, I actually watch anime
0%.
>> is the number one.
>> saw Keffals tweet.
>> Yeah, her pronunciation hurts. It always
does when a foreigner starts learning a
language. Yeah.
>> How bo- uh how bo-how or
>> Okay, I can hear that one. That didn't
sound good.
>> How
>> I don't even know Chinese and I know
that's not how you say it.
>> How
>> This sounds like me and This sounds like
Maple Neia trying to teach me French in
the donations at the end of the night.
Hey Ian, Hasan went to China. You should
go to China now. You go TO CHINA NOW.
>> [laughter]
>> Y'ALL CAN BARELY speak English. And why
the [__] are they saying I'm learning
Chinese? Chinese ain't a [__]
language. They're learning Mandarin or
I'm not even going to try on that one. I
don't know. I just assumed it was a
language. I'm wrong. Mandarin is what
she was bab- uh babbling. It's an
insanely complicated language for
Westerners given that she bragged about
not being able to read. This is Wait,
what? She can't read?
I bet your French is better. I bet it's
not. I bet it's not.